[Musique]
actuellement vous êtes en zone interdite
de contraventions vous avez que s'est
défendu de stationner éternel farceur
piemme ici dans les rues d'orléans
impose de fausses amendes sur les
pare-brise le dessinateur cet été en
touraine à notre dame d'oé où il vivait
depuis les années 70 crocker d'actualité
pour le figaro et la croix bienne s'est
fait connaître du grand public grâce à
ses revues de presse réalisée en direct
pour l'émission le petit rapporteur en
france pour le moment
son humour caustique piemme l'a exercé
jusque sur le plateau du jt de france 3
centre val de loire pour sert plutôt à
traiter des sujets graves
dur de la gaudriole qui va n'a pas
besoin c'est la grosse blague scène de
défense de son vrai nom pierre georges
marie de barrigue de montvallon le
dessinateur affiché volontiers des idées
de gauche
on le voit ici dans une manifestation
contre la guerre en irak en 2003 père
d'une famille nombreuse d'humoristes
aimer les enfants qui lui rendait bien
le dessinateur n'a eu de cesse de
croquer la vie comme un dernier trait
d'humour piemme a cassé sa pipe le jour
de son anniversaire
mais moi je marque fait religieux est
irrésistible extraordinaire m
modeste slap le frein